la France insoumise condamne tous les
crimes de guerre ils sont passibles je
le rappelle pour mes collègues de la
Cour pénale internationale et j'alerte
les bombes qui tombent sur Gaza ne sont
pas plus acceptables que les atrocités
du Hamas le siège total de Gaza en cours
et une violation du droit international
rappelée encore récemment par l'ONU
depuis le début du conflit les ONG
réclament avec l'Organisation Mondiale
de la Santé un couloir humanitaire pour
appuyer la réponse médicale et le
respect du droit international collègue
un seul message devrait parvenir du
concer des nations en cette heure si
grave comme l'a fait le secrétaire
général de l'ONU l'Irlande la Suisse
l'Espagne la Norvège le Mexique et tant
de pays il faut appeler au cesser le feu
comment pensez-vous qu'on puisse
relancer ce processus euh de paix pour
euh aboutir à cette solution des deux
états on ne peut pas mettre sur le même
plan comme vous l'avez fait les crimes
de guerre des Israéliens et des
Palestiniens on ne peut pas rester
insensible
à ce que j'appellerai le retour de la
barbarie dans notre monde vous avez dit
citant je crois monsieur Guinard que
nous choisissions le monde dans lequel
nous allons vivre et bien le monde dans
lequel nous vivons n'est pas un monde où
les enfants ont le droit d'être égorgés
ça ne signifie pas qu'il y a une
exigence de justice cette justice elle
passe par d'un État palestinien au côté
d'un état israélien mais l'urgence du
moment au nom des valeurs que vous
mettez sur la table c'est précisément de
ne pas mettre sur le même plan les
égorgeur et les victimes civiles de Gaza
Israël estant une authentique démocratie
j'ai presque envie de vous dire que ce
sera d'une part à une commission
d'enquête lié à cette guerre mais
d'autre part et surtout aux citoyens
israéliens de
de remplir leur devoirs CIVI comme bon
leur semble et si leur semble bon de
mettre un gouvernement qui plus
centriste voire de centre gauche
souhaiterait revenir à un processus de
paix c'est tout à fait possible et la
deuxième condition c'est les non pas
lesadication parce que je pense qu'on
n'éradique pas un mouvement qui fait du
social du j'oserais pas dire du
spirituel mais du religieux de
l'éducatif et pas seulement du
terrorisme je pense que le ramas ne peut
pas tant qu'il ne sera pas désarmé au
sens le plus physique trivial et
militaire du terme euh là non plus on on
n'aura pas de possibilité de revenir sur
les rails d'un processus de paix en
dépit de tous ces défauts que j'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure l'autorité
palestienne est le seul interlocuteur
légal et légitime euh de pour vis-à-vis
de la communauté internationale pour
rétablir les conditions d'un processus
de paix avec Israël